let's explore
the infinite series so we're going to
start at n equals 1 and go to infinity
of negative 1 to the n plus 1
over n squared which is going to be
equal to let's see when n is 1 it's
going to be this is going to be positive
it's going to be 1 and it's going to go
minus 1 over 2 squared so it's minus 1 4
plus
1 9
minus
1
16
plus one over twenty five i'm actually
going to go pretty far
minus one over 36 plus
one over 49 minus one over 64.
and yeah that's pretty good i'll stop
there and of course we keep going on and
on and on and it's an alternating series
plus minus just keeps going on and on
and on and on forever
now we know from previous tests and in
fact the alternating series test this
satisfies the constraints of the
alternating series test and we're able
to show that it converges what we're
doing now is actually trying to estimate
what things converge to so we want to
converge so we would not converge we
want to estimate what this value s is
and we're going to do that by doing a
finite number of calculations by not
having to add this entire thing together
and so let's estimate it by taking let's
say the partial sum of the first four
terms
so let's take these four terms right
over here and let's call that so that's
going to be s
sub 4. and then you're going to have a
remainder which is going to be
everything else so all of this other
stuff i don't want even the brackets to
end that's going to be your remainder
the
remainder to get to your actual sum
or whatever's left over when you just
take the first four terms so this is
from the fifth term all the way to
infinity and we've seen this before so
the actual sum is going to be equal to
this partial sum
plus this remainder well we can
calculate this this is going to be let's
see common denominator here see
9 times 16 is 144 so it's going to be 1
44 and then that's going to be
144
minus 36 over 144 plus 16 over 144
minus 9 over 144 let's see that is 144
30 negative 36 plus 16 is negative minus
20. so it's 124 minus 9 is 115. so this
is all going to be equal to
115 over 144. i didn't even need a
calculator figure that out plus some
remainder plus some
remainder
and so if we could figure out some
bounds on this remainder we will figure
out the bounds on our actual
on our actual sum will i be able to
figure out well how far is this away
from this right over here
and there's two ways to think about it
so let's let's let's look at it so the
the first thing i want to see is i want
to show you that this remainder right
over here is definitely going to be
positive and i actually encourage you to
pause the video and see if you can prove
to yourself that this remainder over
here is definitely going to be
positive
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
let's write the remainder down so
actually i'll just write it actually
i'll write it up here so r sub 4 is
1 over
25
1 over 20 actually i don't even have to
write it separately i could show you in
just right over here that this is going
to be positive how do i show that well
we just pair let's just create put some
parentheses in here and just pair these
terms like this
so 1 over 25 minus 1 over 36 136 is less
than 1 over 25 this one's positive this
one's negative so this is positive then
you have a positive term subtracting
from that a smaller negative term so
this is going to be positive and so if
you just pair all of these terms up
you're just going to have a whole series
of positive terms so just like that we
have established that r sub 4
or r4 we could call it is going to be
greater than 0.
so r 4 is going to be greater than 0.
and now the other thing i want to prove
is that this remainder is going to be
less than the first term that we haven't
calculated that the remainder is going
to be less than 1 over 25 and once again
i encourage you to pause the video and
see if you can
put some parentheses here in a certain
way that will convince you that this
entire infinite sum here this remainder
is going to sum up to something that's
less than this first term
once again i'm assuming you've had to go
at it so let's just write it down so
i'll do that same pink color
so our remainder when we just use when
we take the partial sum of the first
four terms so it's 1 over 25 and the way
i'm going to write it instead of writing
minus 1 over 36 i'm going to write minus
and i'm going to put the parentheses now
between the second around the second and
third terms so this is going to be 1
over 36. minus
1 over 49
and then we're going to have minus
1 over 64
minus actually the next term is going to
be 1 over 9 squared 1 over 81
and then minus and we keep going like
that on and on and on on and on and on
forever now notice what happens
this
this term right over here is positive
we have a larger we have a smaller
number being subtracted from a larger
number
this term right over here is positive so
we're starting with 125 and then we're
subtracting a bunch of positive things
from it so this thing has to be less
than 1 over 25
so r sub 4
is going to be less than 1 over 25
or we could even write that as r sub 4
is less than 0.04 0.04 same thing as 1
over 25. and actually this this logic
right over here is is is the basis for
the proof of the alternating series test
this probably this should make you feel
pretty good that hey look this thing is
going to be greater than zero and you
could and it's it's increasing the more
terms that you add to it but it's
bounded by it's bounded from above it's
bounded from above at 1 over 25 which is
a pretty good sense that hey this thing
is going to converge but that's not what
we're going to concern ourselves with
here here we just care about this range
the sum is the sum of these two things
and so
the entire sum
is going to be less than 115
115 over 144 plus the upper bound on r4
so plus
0.04 and it's going to be greater than
it's going to be
greater than
it's going to be greater than our
partial sum plus 0 because this
remainder is definitely greater than
zero so you could just it's going to be
greater than
our partial sum and just like that just
doing a calculation that i was able to
do with hand we're able to get pretty
nice bounds around this infinite series
infinite series
and let's let's now get the calculator
out just to get a little bit better
sense of things so if we say 115
divided by 144
that's
0.79861 repeating so this is
0.79861
repeating is less than s which is less
than this thing plus .04
so let me write that down so
so plus
.04
gets us point eight three eight six one
repeating eight three eight six one
repeating
so actually i could have done that in my
head i know i resorted to a calculator
zero point eight three eight six
one repeating and just like that we just
just a calculation we're able to do on
by hand we were able to come up with a
pretty good
approximation for s and the and the the
the big takeaway from here and we're
gonna build on this but this was really
to give you the intuition with a very
concrete example is is when you have an
alternating series like this the type of
alternating series that satisfies the
alternating series test where you can
write it as negative 1 to the n or
negative 1 to the n plus 1 times the
series of positive terms that are
decreasing and whose limits go to zero
as n approaches infinity not only do
those things not only do those things
converge
but you can estimate your error based on
the first term that you are not
including now this was a one example
there's going to be it's going to be
different depending on the whether the
first term is negative or positive and
we're going to have to introduce the
idea of absolute value there the
magnitude but the big takeaway here is
that the magnitude of your error is
going to be no more
than the magnitude of the first term
that you're not including in your
partial sum